hey guys I'm just McDonald it is the
twenty-first of februari and here are my
top five favorite stories of the whole
week far and away the funniest thing I
school this week apart from this picture
is the flappy bird mmm oh what a word
that rhymes with cluster duck it is
flappy bird himself looks pretty frickin
silly but thousands of him all doing the
same jerky flying / falling maneuver
controlled by people all over the globe
is just hilarious the MMO is exactly
what you'd expect you're still that same
old flappy bird but around you at
thousands of player-controlled ghosts
flappy birds trying to achieve their own
flappy destiny the madness is over at
flap MMO com if you want to see it in
action next up that multi-platform
graphics comparison video from metal
gear ground zeroes that we've been
telling you about is out in all its
glory if you do feel the need to check
out exactly what the differences in
quality are between the lower frame
rates of last gen and the slightly lower
720p resolution of Xbox one then that's
a thing you'll be able to do next gen
really does look lovely and crisp but
let me know if you find these videos
useful and if there's a particular game
you'd want to see this sort of
comparison video done for next up if
you're playing titanfall on the Xbox one
you're doing it wrong or at least I
guess that's what Nvidia would have to
say the 149 dollar nvidia gtx 750ti has
been unveiled and it looks pretty sweet
based on its maxwell architecture the
company is claiming it has twice to
performance per watt of Kepler and less
power consumption the 750 ti and 750
models will feature two DVI output and
HDMI alongside these nvidia have also
announced the gtx titan black the
successor to the uber powerful and
expensive GTX Titan you can find all the
nit picky details on gamespot now let me
know what your pc setup is in the
comments and whether you reckon you'll
upgrade
second to last from the week that was
Microsoft has started inviting gamers to
an xbox one beta program said program
allows Xbox Live members who are
selected to preview Xbox one features
before they become publicly available
and give that feedback prior to launch
the beta program is started today and
involve the preview of the March for
Xbox one update which encompasses a fix
for party chat ahead of titan falls
launched on the 11th microsoft are
letting people know they've been
selected through a message on xbox live
it seems the ps4 is yet to let Sony down
since the console is now almost doubling
the sales of the Xbox one the NPD posted
their sales numbers for the month of
January and although the specific data
isn't public PlayStation have come out
to tell us that in their words ps4 with
number one in sales for next-gen
consoles in January nearly doubling that
of the nearest next-gen competitor this
also means that the ps4 is taken over
the top spot from the form of
frontrunner Nintendo's 3ds the xbox one
popped in 2nd were you expecting the ps4
to come out on top and do reckon the
xbox one will be able to close the gap
you can let me know in the comments or
on my Twitter this week on site camon
subfinder true love in Skyrim mods
Johnny wraps up the flappy bird insanity
on feed bakula and Danny continues to
find romance with pigeons on random
encounter that is it from me this week
but I'll be back again on Monday with
more news so until then be sure to have
a great weekend